alright y'all so today I'm going to
surprise someone who I am extremely
grateful for that works on the Kelly
Clarkson show with an ambush thank you
[Music]
if you haven't seen me do this before I
read a letter just someone on my staff
to say thank you and thank them for all
their hard work and surprise deliver it
to them what's up Jason okay so this is
called ambush thank you I wrote you a
letter Lisa thank you so much for being
the greatest teleprompter goddess and
all of the universe today we're gonna do
something a little bit different though
I want to thank the executive producer
on our show Alex Duda because when she's
awesome and to because she's always
standing on the side of the stage
prompting me with cue cards kind of
telling what to say because we've gone
through the briefing and the whole show
and everything but kind of recapping
during the interview so she's I'd
literally be lost in the show without
her and this show would be lost better
she is kind of a glute for this whole
show so here you go I'm gonna write him
on cue cards because it's gonna cute
because she's always giving me notes on
cue cards there we go okay
[Music]
brain and it's going to get her right
now Brandon is my husband / manager I
feel like you know that Love Actually
scene Oh Brandon is searching for her
drama will we find her
MAME I hope she's like doing a number
one over to New York now I'm oh yeah I
should make you read them I'm gonna make
you read them all right I wrote this for
you listen you're my ambush thank you
because of all of this do you have to
read this and I'm gonna be your cue card
person okay ready okay Brandon and I
couldn't have asked for a better
teammate to do this show with you are
outstanding and incredible at lip Oh
putting every single show together and
have gathered the most amazing humans to
make up our entire step the crew is
equip look I'm not gonna bet I know you
are probably exhausted a lot of the time
because this is a lot of work but please
know that all of us not just me are so
appreciative
why are you doing is you make me cry of
all your brilliance your talent and
passion my Torres sister I want to thank
you and also that I think we are going
to be here for a minute so I happy to
show you don't even know my Torres I'm
so excited for the show
it's successful and it is a mainly to do
with all of your battles behind the
camera really really oh my god I can't
let me do that after a long day then
you're gonna come in here yeah I was
like I was trying to tell him I was like
me I want to do Alex and I was trying to
think of a cute idea so I was like oh
yeah show us those cute cards are you
all right ambush thank you out what
Brandon he likes to scare people that's
what he does so you never expect that at
the end of a long day I'm so grateful to
be on the show I feel we have a really
special team and it all true
goes down from our leader which is Kelly
and she sets the tone around here so we
just when we first met her that's what
she asked for which was a great culture
on the team so we're so lucky that we
get to work for her and with each other
cuz I think we have awesome humans on
this team just as she always says and
it's really sweet that she thanked me
Kelly is a unique up read human herself
because she does always tell us not just
me everyone she always wants to know who
booked that story or which team was that
she took the time to get to know
everyone's name on the staff before the
Christmas party that is unusual and
wonderful and and precious and I think
I'm not alone in feeling grateful to be
on the show everything she said which
was so well written and so I don't know
heartwarming I feel the exact same way I
feel lucky to be on the show and it
means a lot that she would take the time
to to ambush thank you me subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going